il s'appelle christophe sand hill et
lensois et il est comédien
comment l'architecte devient ton
mangeurs de hamburgers en fait parce que
je ne suis pas demandeur devrait
hamburger bien placé pour le dire que
j'en ai mangé une vingtaine
enfin pas manger vraiment de se dire que
c'était bon
non ce n'est que là j'ai commencé à
faire des fausses pubs avant d'en faire
détruire
j'avais côtoyé des copains d'ailleurs de
deux villes qui connaissaient déjà
évidemment dessinée est donc l'équipe de
dahra qui ré où il y avait des vélos riz
tous les mardis soir face à bale bureau
pendant ces derniers trois prix et avec
la tronche que j'ai sans proposer de me
prendre pour des romans photos et des
publicités ça a commencé comme ça alors
christophe comment il tenait la dalle le
même jour et ceux qui adorent dans les
épiceries ont fait un casting cirque ont
choisi le comédien pour ses qualités
professionnelles
voilà merci
ce qui m'a permis de faire ma propre
publicité et c'est aussi pour ça j'ai
pas de complexe
j'avoue c'est sans dire que la fumée
péjoratif c'est un peu le cas pour un
pont pour collégiens qui hésitent afin
d'aider plus parce qu'ils ont peur des
grilles et de devenir comme le ducrocq
qui se décarcassent kiko du crew et sept
comédiens la tendance heures bientôt ça
fait déjà pas mal de temps
ça fait presque un non sens et
commercial a dans son budget en dessous
si vous deviez faire une pub pour les
doigts dans la prise qu'est ce qu'on ne
ferait rien je les mettrais vraiment mal
l'esprit est le même ça c'est plus
pratique on battait doigt dedans est-ce
que c'est pas du tout sexy c'est vous
qu'il ya un revirement magistralement
dérisoire de la publicité à l'automne
oui est-ce qu'il n'y avait plus que des
oreilles et mes soeurs et oui il ya eu
beaucoup de pub qui sont passés aux
bahamas ou à tahiti charles banny n'est
fait et j'ai touché six mois dès
maintenant c'est le seul de son jeu
[Musique]